we begin this morning with the home
stretch of the presidential race
on the last weekend of campaigning the
candidates are sweeping out across
the most hotly contested states joe
biden is in michigan today and he'll be
joined by former president barack obama
biden's running mate senator kamala
harris makes three stops in florida
meanwhile vice president mike pence
visits north carolina where he'll make
two appearances
and president trump holds four rallies
in pennsylvania
the keystone state is seen as the key to
the election
with 20 electoral votes up for grabs
both campaigns have been pushing hard
there
in the closing days of the race last
night the president held a socially
distanced rally in minnesota
a state he's hoping to add to his column
after narrowly losing it
in 2016. the last minute campaigning
comes as the u.s hit another
record high for coronavirus infections
in a single day
again on friday when nearly a hundred
thousand new cases
were reported paula reid kicks off our
coverage from minneapolis this morning
paula
good morning good morning michelle
in these last few days before the
election president trump is hitting
these key
battleground states but many of these
states are also coveted hot spots
including here in minnesota where last
night the state's governor
restricted the size of the president's
event as the state hit a record
in new covid cases hello rochester
president trump hammered the state's
democratic governor for limiting his
rally to just
250 supporters following covet outbreaks
tied to two previous rallies held there
there are at least 25 000 people who
wanted to be here tonight they were here
for a long time they waited and waited
and
then the governor did bad things with
kovid raging in every swing state he hit
friday
the president still tried to downplay
the virus it's a pandemic and you're
doing good
but in michigan a state he carried in
2016
and now trails biden by eight points
covet hospitalizations are up 96 percent
since october first it's always cases
are up and people go crazy you know
now it's you live with it and you have
and you know what to do we understand it
now you got to understand it
but we're making that beautiful turn mr
trump tried to undermine confidence in
the death toll
by falsely suggesting doctors
intentionally over
report covid deaths you know our doctors
get more money if somebody dies from
kelvin
that's true it's like two thousand
dollars more
so you get more money the president's
rally in green bay was criticized by the
local hospital system
which warned it was a bad idea given the
city has one of the highest infection
rates in the nation
no i don't at all no and they're outdoor
rallies
they're all outdoors the president's
attempts to downplay the virus are
undermined by evidence from the cdc
cbs news has learned cdc data shows
cases are
surging in 49 states on a call with
state governors
coronavirus task force member dr debra
burks warned
we're seeing now on surge across the
northern part of the united states we
now have about 1200 counties almost a
third of the country
in our hot spot category
today president trump will make four
stops in pennsylvania
a pivotal swing state that he won in
2016
but recent polls show him trailing
former vice president joe biden
jeff paula thank you very much